after a gap of 24 years the Union flag
is going to be flown and worn in space
once again
I've been overwhelmed by the amount of
support that has been
we couldn't ask for a better ambassador
for human spaceflight
this is his dream and he's lucky enough
to be able to fulfill it
it's really an emotional moment really
feel and live with them through this
moment
now we're just ready to get on with the
mission and get to work
and liftoff
dawn on the snow sprinkle steppes of
Kazakhstan and the rocket that will take
the first British astronaut to the space
station is making its final terrestrial
journey the Soyuz is 50 metres long and
weighs more than 300 tons it takes a
beast of a train to haul it from the
Assembly hangar to its launch pad at the
Baikonur cosmodrome
Space Flight TM a 19 M will be the five
hundred and third manned launch from the
spaceport squeezed into a capsule behind
the white casing is a crew of three Tim
Peake is flight engineer - and it's two
days until he blasts off it's always a
happy place to be here of course but if
it's really a close friend or somebody
of your people that you're launching and
you have the family close by it's really
an emotional moment and you really feel
and live with them through this moment
major Tim is ex Army Air Corps and a
former helicopter test pilots with more
than 3,000 flying hours but it's taken
another six years of training with the
European Space Agency to prepare him for
a six-month stint on the International
Space Station
is simulated microgravity in NASA's deep
water pool he's learned survival skills
and the Russian wilderness experienced
extreme g-force in a giant spinning
centrifuge and he sweated for 120 hours
in the confines of a Soyuz capsule
learning the manual then practicing
again and again for everything that
could go wrong from a computer glitch to
an emergency loss of pressure I think
it's really important to have a
high-fidelity simulator because the more
accurately you can train and the more
realistically you can train then the
better you'll do your job in space from
the training that I've done you know
here and in in Europe in Germany in
Japan and in the u.s. of course it all
put it all together and it really does
prepare you very well for the mission
it's the day before launch time for
traditions the rocket is blessed by a
Russian Orthodox priest the watching
crowds aren't left out
the Soyuz is now shrouded by metal work
it'll peel back in the minutes before
launch revealing Tim's rocket
it's the final touches on years of hard
work much of his time will be spent
running more than 250 science
experiments its power inspiring the next
generation of astronauts and space
scientists young people have already
designed the mission logo chosen the
mission name Principia and
with a bit of expert help created Tim's
space menu it's 24 hours to launch zoom
would it be villa Ko britannia yoga the
world's media have come to watch the
last news conference before launch next
to Tim is Russian commander yuri
malenchenko nasa as tim kopra then the
backup crew they won't get to fly this
time Tim's wife and two sons are also in
Kazakhstan he's done what he can to
prepare them I've made sure that we've
spoken about the training they've been
to see me at Johnson Space Center
through the space station mock-up
facilities they've seen where I'm going
to eat where I'm gonna sleep where I'm
going to use they'll do which is the
most exciting part for them Tim's
parents are proud of their son and what
they say is his tremendous adventure he
blasts off with his mom's blessing we
used to joke when this first started I
said I wish it would be a banker and
work in a bank then I'd know where you
were every day but this is his dream
he's lucky enough
the morning of the launch - an old
Russian song about a cosmonaut pining
for home it's a short walk to the buses
from the hotel where Tim has been
quarantined so he doesn't fall sick he's
in good spirits
goodbyes are never easy especially when
you're four and daddy's going to the
space station
at home excitement builds a day of
events for one and a half thousand
children and school teachers in the
Science Museum and at Tim Peaks old
school Westbourne house and Chester
good luck messages from young fans
at building to five for the very final
preparations are underway the crew
addressed and they're made to measure
suckle survival suits the check for
pressure leaks in replica Soyuz seats
for six year old Thomas and Oliver who's
four is a chance to collect another
spectacular photo for the album they're
ready
walking out carrying their ventilation
packs that cool their suits
and he's back on board the bus blown
kisses and fist bumps with the boys
the last face-to-face contact for six
months for white Rebecca it's a relief
that Nikes he's off so next time we see
or maybe clothing which will be also and
how you doing dresses great I can't wait
I can't wait to see it this has been a
long journey so it's just fab to get to
this point
they'll now wait in the capsule for two
hours going through checklists and
listening to tracks they've chosen three
each for Tim its Queen Coldplay and u2
the choice of Lady gaga causes some
amusement and in the final few minutes
time just to reflect on the journey
ahead watching a mile away the boys join
in the countdown
Tata sequence initiation in commission
a second service tower separation
boosters igniting the engines firing
ramping up to flight speed liftoff of
tim kopra yuri malenchenko and timothy
peake on their way to the International
Space Station
25 seconds engines are stable there's no
three people on earth that are more
focused than the crew of the Soyuz there
a pitch maneuver 30 seconds in tilts the
rocket to achieve the right orbit and
you can feel the vehicle steering it's a
funny it's it's as if you're balancing a
broomstick it's an important moment
because you're enjoying this sensation
of acceleration as fuel is used up
stages of the rocket are discarded three
in total stage is jettisoned then the G
drops a little bit past about half a G
before the next stage kicks in so if you
imagine lumpy and bumpy it starts very
gradually and then it gets heavier and
heavier as you accelerate harder and
harder five minutes in and the crew feel
a g-force three times their own weight
the fairing is blown away and that's the
first time you can't even see out of the
window so gorgeous blues and whites and
like clouds you can see below and the
block of space the engine shut off
congratulations on orbital insertion
thank you nine minutes into the flight
the engines cut out with a jolt and Tim
feels weightlessness for the first time
140 miles up he's made it into orbit the
camera that's been capturing their
progress flickers and dies
the crew still has another six hours
before they arrive at the International
Space Station the Soyuz is in orbit at
an altitude of 140 miles mission control
must now do it sums to catch up with the
ISS orbiting 250 miles above the earth
the first engine burn moves the Soyuz
from its insertion orbit up into a
so-called phasing orbit the process is
repeated to move it into the same orbit
as the ISS a side thruster then changes
the Soyuz Direction slightly so it can't
crash into the ISS a radar is activated
that locks onto the ISS from 100 miles
out six hours later major Tim made the
final approach to the ISS a moment of
hesitation and then they docked after a
pause to check the seal was tight the
hatch opened and Tim floated aboard the
first british astronaut on the space
station a moment to celebrate for his
family then the extra-terrestrial phoned
home
it was fantastic to watch that he's a
long way from home but Tim's amazing
adventure has only just begun
this is Baikonur house